[Musik]
guten Abend zu einer kompakten Halbzeit
Ausgabe wir blicken nach New York zur
ersten Anklage gegen einen ehemaligen
US-Präsidenten von Donald Trump werden
heute Fingerabdrücke genommen
Polizeifotos geschossen anschließend
wird die Anklage verlesen ein
historischer Vorgang begleitet von
riesigem Medieninteresse und all das
könnte Trump in die Karten spielen für
seine erneute Präsidentschaftskandidatur
mehr von Claudia Bates
Trump hat mit allem Recht gehabt meinen
die einen kauft ihm seine Lügen nicht ab
die anderen Demonstrationen für und
gegen den Ex-Präsidenten Trump selbst
hatte zu Protesten aufgerufen nutzt die
Anklage um Anhänger zu mobilisieren
eine Anklage zu erfinden gegen einen
früheren Präsidenten und
Präsidentschaftskandidaten ein trauriger
Tag für unser Land
ich möchte mich zur Wehr setzen gegen
Hassrede in meiner Stadt und gegen die
Ideologie von weißer Vorherrschaft in
Amerika
vor dem Gericht hunderte Journalisten
aus der ganzen Welt eine
Videoübertragung aus dem Saal hat der
Richter abgelehnt hier wird es nachher
um die schweigegeldzahlung an die
Pornodarstellerin stormy Daniels gehen
das Geld soll von der trump-organisation
falsch verbucht worden sein außerdem
steht illegale Wahlkampffinanzierung im
Raum New York im Ausnahmezustand
35.000 Polizisten sind bereit für den
Einsatz die Polizeichefin mit einer
deutlichen Warnung bei uns in destruct
Gewalt und Zerstörung sind nicht Teil
rechtmäßiger Meinungsäußerung und werden
in unserer Stadt nicht toleriert
Donald Trump selbst ist noch in seinem
Trump Tower mitten in Manhattan in einer
guten Stunde muss er vor dem Richter
erscheinen
vor dem New Yorker Gerichtsgebäude steht
Johannes Hano für uns was passiert
aktuell
also Donald Trump hat den Trump Tower
noch nicht verlassen es wird erwartet
dass er dort jeden Moment losfährt und
dann hier nach Downtown Manhattan kommt
um dann hier dem districturnal also dem
Staatsanwalt erstmal vorgeführt zu
werden er wird ja dann empfangen von ein
ich guck mal zwei dreihundert
Demonstranten vielleicht pro Tram gegen
Trump das läuft ja alles im Moment sehr
friedlich habt die Polizei ist entspannt
man muss sagen das Medieninteresse ist
sehr viel größer das haben sie hier sehr
viel mehr Medien Leute versammelt als
Demonstranten wenn Donald Trump dann
hier ankommt dann wird der
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt es wird
wohl kein Polizeifoto von ihm gemacht
werden das heißt es gibt schon genügend
Fotos von ihm man würde ihn sowieso
erkennen wenn er flüchten sollte er wird
dann aber Fingerabdrücke machen und dann
wird er auf dem Weg ins Gericht zum rich
haftrechter wurde an einer Kamera vorbei
laufen im Gericht selbst ist keine
Kamera erlaubt aber im Vorjahr wird es
eine geben und es wird damit gerechnet
dass er dann ein kurzes Statement
abgeben wird im Gericht sei selber wird
ihm die Anklageschrift vorgelesen und
dann wird er sich relativ zügig abmachen
zurück nach my Lago war heute Abend eine
Pressekonferenz angekündigt hat und die
Staatsanwaltschaft hier hat angekündigt
dass man wenn Donald Trump den Saal
verlassen hat selbst eine
Pressekonferenz machen wird und dann
erst werden wir erfahren wofür Donald
Trump hier wirklich angeklagt wird
vielen Dank nach New York Johannes Hano
und wir halten Sie in unsere
Nachrichtensendung hier auf dem
Laufenden
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat eine
investitionsgarantie für deutsche
Unternehmen in der Ukraine in Aussicht
gestellt wenn deren Betriebe durch
Angriffe zerstört würden dann haftet der
deutsche Staat für die Investition am
zweiten Tag seines Ukraine Besuchs
vereinbarte habe ich außerdem eine
Energiepartnerschaft aufzubauen
Deutschland will dem von Russland
angegriffen Land gezielter helfen seine
Versorgung mit Strom und Brennstoff
klimafreundlich zu sichern
der Ukraine Krieg hat Finnland dazu
bewogen sich als NATO Mitglied zu
bewerben heute fand die feierliche
Aufnahme in Brüssel statt damit sind die
Finnen des 31 Mitglied im westlichen
Militärbündnis strategisch von großer
Bedeutung Finnland hat eine mehr als
1.300 km lange Grenze zu Russland und
eine gut ausgerüstete Armee ultra
berichtet
die finnische Fahne wird vor dem
Hauptquartier der NATO ist seit dem
Angriffskrieg Russlands ist das
Bedürfnis nach Schutz in Europa
gewachsen deshalb will Finnland nicht
mehr neutral bleiben
herzlich willkommen in der NATO
Finnland ist ein militärisch starkes
Land mehr als 100 Kampfjets besitzt die
Luftwaffe
das ist ein bedeutsamer Tag für Finnland
auch die NATO profitiert von unserem
Beitritt wir haben in unsere
Verteidigung seit Jahrzehnten investiert
wir haben ein starkes Militär wir werden
viel für die Sicherheit in Nordeuropa
leisten
ein Blick auf die Karte zeigt die
strategische Bedeutung Finnlands
1340 km ist die Grenze zu Russland lang
die NATO rückt näher heran Moskau droht
deshalb mit Gegenmaßnahmen
Generalsekretär Stoltenberg spricht von
einem bedeutenden Tag Putins Krieg sei
auch ein strategischer Fehler
wollte weitere NATO Mitglieder
verhindern mit seinem Krieg hat er genau
das Gegenteil erreicht wir haben jetzt
mehr Mitglieder mehr Truppen sind
stärker
die NATO wird mächtiger der
Angriffskrieg Russlands hat die
Militärbündnis neue Stärke verliehen
[Musik]
die Union will einen Bundestags
Untersuchungsausschuss beantragen es
geht um die Rolle von Bundeskanzler
Scholz im Steuer Skandal der Hamburger
Warburg Bank während seiner Zeit als
Erster Bürgermeister Hamburgs war auf
eine Millionen schwere Rückerstattung
der Bank an den Fiskus verzichtet worden
im Raum steht die Frage ob die Politik
Einfluss auf die Finanzbehörden genommen
hatte
anderthalb Jahre dauerte die Hängepartie
um den insolventen Flughafen
Frankfurt-Hahn jetzt hat er einen neuen
Besitzer der Airport im Hunsrück geht an
die Trierer Trio AG des Unternehmers
Peter Adrian hier rechts im Bild über
die Kaufsumme wurde Stillschweigen
vereinbart die Immobilienfirma trebo
will gezielt in die Infrastruktur am
Hahn investieren alle 400 Beschäftigten
werden übernommen
bei einem schweren Zugunglück in den
Niederlanden ist ein Gleisarbeiter
getötet worden etwa 30 Menschen wurden
verletzt auf der Strecke Amsterdam Den
Haag waren am frühen Morgen zwei Züge
auf einen Baukran geprallt darunter ein
Intercity der entgleiste und in ein Feld
raste die Unfallursache ist noch unklar
König Wilhelm Alexander sprach den
Angehörigen der Opfer sein Mitgefühl aus
heute Nacht wieder frostig obs zu Ostern
milder wird erfahren Sie gleich von
Christa Orden um 21:45 Uhr das heute
journal morgen übernimmt hier Jana
pareises das war's von uns in aller
Kürze jetzt weiterhin viel Spaß bei der
zweiten Halbzeit Eintracht gegen Union
[Musik]
ja guten Abend die aufgeblühten Pflanzen
die bekommen das jetzt noch einmal mit
frostigen Nächten zu tun wie die
vergangene so wird es auch in der
kommenden Nacht außer an den Küsten
überall frostig an den Alpen gibt es bis
minus acht Grad dazu ist der Himmel oft
klar nur im Nordosten mit dichteren
Wolken etwas Regen mit Schnee vermischt
das breitet sich morgen zwischen der
Ostsee und dem Erzgebirge aus sodass es
dann hier und damals Regen oder
Schneeregen gibt je weitere Richtung
Westen oder Richtung Süden kommen desto
sonniger wird der Tag am Rhein sind die
zweistellige Werte möglich in der
Osthälfte bleibt es mit vier bis acht
Grad kühl bis Ostern wird es dann zwar
etwas milder aber auch wechselhafter
tschüss